okay so the next talk is by milad
barzagar
uh on paving property of strong rally
measures
okay thank you and thank
the organizers nice to be here
this is a joint work with castrati
let me start by recalling a definition
let x be a random subset of a set of
integers from 1 to n
and mu be its distribution so mu is a
probability measure on
the subsets of the set
another way to look at this is that you
can take x to be a random and
dimensional
0 1 vector and then mu
becomes a probability measure on say a
dimensional hypercube uh
i will mostly use the first point of
view but
towards the end i will come back to the
second point of view
so anyways this x or mu is called
strongly rayleigh if this polynomial
here
is stable i've used this notation
z to the power a is this monomial
and yeah this polynomial is called the
probability generating polynomial
okay so uh why is the definition
important uh this notion of
strongly raviness is the most natural
notion of negative dependence
this was demonstrated by orchard brandon
and leget
and here is a re list of reasons for
this statement
i'm not going to go through them
so let's continue
now i will explain intuitively what
i mean by paving property so
the setting is that we have this space
of endpoints here
and we want to choose a random
strongly rayleigh subset of these points
as i mentioned
the points here are negatively dependent
and
it means that there's this sort of
repulsive force between the points uh it
means that
if for example if you include one sub
a certain subset of these points in x
then
the probability that any other subsets
any disjoint subsets is included in x
drops so
yeah there's this kind of repulsion
between the points
so let me tell you
what the paving property say says
it says that it is possible to partition
the space into a number of subsets such
that
the points in each of these subsets are
almost independent
uh so these points are almost
independent these are
almost independent and so on and the
number of the subsets
only depends on how much independence we
want
okay so
this is uh appealing from an
intuitive point of view because
what it says is that this repulsive
force between the points can't be
strong so for example
if the number of the points in the space
are
very large and we have fixed the notion
of
almost independence then for example in
the largest subset
of these sets in the partition
there's a lot of points that are almost
independent which are
weakly correlated to each other so i
will show you a
formal uh statement of this
result but before that i want to tell
you a little bit about
the ideas that we use in the proof
and how we go about formalizing this
idea
okay so um i claim that this
idea resembles the paving conjecture
which you are familiar with so
uh paving conjecture uh
which is a theorem now uh it was proved
by marcus schpelmann
and i think in 2014 if i'm not
wrong so it states that
for every positive epsilon there is an
integer
r which only depends on epsilon such
that every hermitian matrix
m with zero diagonal can be r epsilon p
and this means that if m is n by n
so uh
uh so number the rows and the columns by
one to n then the set can be partitioned
into r
subsets such that this holds here
uh here this is the operator norm and
this is the principal sub matrix of m
whose
which is the intersection of the rows
and columns
with numbers in sk okay
so how does this connect to the paving
property
this happens in the case of determinant
point processes so
let's expand subset of the set this is
just
uh this is just a finite point process
uh so i mean discrete point process
so this x is called determinantal if
there is a hermitian matrix k
such that this happens for every a the
probability that
a is included in x is just the
determinant of the corresponding
principles of and k here is called the
kernel of this determinant process
uh it is known that these point
processes are in fact
strongly rayleigh and the nice thing
about them is that
everything can be expressed in terms of
a matrix so
it makes things much easier
so let me recall some facts about
determinant point processes the first
one
is that a hermitian matrix is
the kernel of a determinant process if
and only if
all of its eigen values are between zero
and one
and i will not use it right now i will
use these two
uh facts in the next slide which
follow easily from the definition the
first one says that
x is independent if and only if its
kernel is diagonal
and independent means that it chooses
the point this random subset chooses the
points independently
and the second one says that uh the
restriction of
x to any subset like a is a
is itself determinant and its kernel is
just the corresponding
principles of matrix okay and i
mentioned that
these are strongly rayleigh and
also their probability generating
polynomial has this form here
here's that is just the the diagonal
matrix of the variables
so okay let's now deduce the paving
property for determinant processes
we need a hermitian matrix with zero
diagonal so we subtract the diagonal
and we can apply the paving theorem to
this matrix
then for any epsilon we get a
partition like this here such that this
holds
uh on the right hand side here we should
have a
operator norm of k0 but it's easy to see
that it is less than one
and what this says is that on the left
hand side
what we have is this principle sub
matrix which
is just the kernel of this
restriction of x to s k and we have this
matrix which is diagonal it
is in fact the diagonal of this
matrix here so what this says is that
for each sk in this partition the kernel
of this
restriction of the restriction of
x to each of these subsets is almost
diagonal
so and i mentioned
so this in a sense means that
the points in each of these sets are
almost independent
okay now there are two problems
uh the first one is that the statement
in the previous slide wasn't a nice one
from a probabilistic point of view so we
would like a probabilistic
[Music]
statement this doesn't look like a hard
problem
this looks easy to deal with but the
second problem
is how to deal with a strongly rally
case and this looks a little bit more
scary
and i want to talk about how we
deal with these problems first i will
answer the second
problem because the nature of the first
problem will
change once i do that so
how do we answer the second problem
we extend the paving theorem to real
stable polynomials
this might look like a crazy idea at
first but
it actually is a natural thing to do and
the reason is that
uh in marcus and company's paper
uh they use the the two main steps
are which are called interlacing
families and the barrier method
both of them concern real stable
polynomials
so this is hopeful in a way
but what they do is that they use these
methods to
prove uh reverse conjecture which is
actually equivalent to the pavement
conjecture
and it has this vector balancing
formulation
and they also
deduce the paving conjecture from this
reverse conjecture so anyways uh the the
problem that is that
the the proof really goes in a direction
but
doesn't really generalize to polynomials
so
yeah the ideas and the this proof
don't uh do not directly actually
extend to real stable polynomials
so let me show you their
uh paving results they proved that
for a hit for any hermitian matrix with
zero diagonal there is this
partition such that this happens so they
obtain this
paving band here there is this relation
between the paving bound
and the number of the sets in the
partition
okay but there is this uh paper by
lee karavichandran and they come up with
a direct proof of the paving conjecture
the upset is that they get a better
paving bound
but for us the nice thing is that
the proof actually generalizes to
polynomials
it actually gives you an idea about how
to
formalize an extension of this results
to real stable polynomials and also
again their main methods are interlacing
families and a new version of the
barrier methods
so those work for real stable
polynomials
but of course there are steps that they
use facts from linear algebra they they
prove things about this hermitian matrix
but we were able to just
all the steps actually come through but
we needed to come up with new proof
proofs for some of the steps and we did
that
mainly using interlacing properties of
real stable polynomials together with
some some
simple facts from majorization so
let me show you our results i'm going to
use these notations
the first one i think is standard
this is for a multivariate polynomial
it's diagonalization which we denote by
p
bar is this univariate polynomial here
and the last one says that if q
is a real rooted polynomial and lambda i
are
are its roots then m of q is just the
maximum absolute value of its roots
this is gonna play the role of operator
norm
so uh if you put the characteristic
polynomial of the hermitian matrix here
you just get the
operator norm so yeah this is our result
the constants are the same as lee
karavichandran's result
but we've replaced polynomial uh
matrices with polynomials so we prove
that
for every multi-fine real stable
polynomial
such that the leading coefficient is
equal to one
this isn't this one is not special it
just needs to be
non-zero i think or maybe positive
but i'm gonna just use this case here
i'm just gonna use this
case that's uh leading coefficient is
one
and these coefficients are zero
these are the coefficients of the
monomials of degree one less
this replaces the assumption that
the diagonal of a matrix is zero
then we have this partition such that
this
happens here so there's a well-known
fact that's
if p is real stable then it's
diagonalization is rerouted so
this is well defined here on the
left-hand side we have
we have this weird thing we
differentiate with respect to the
variables
outside of sk it is known that this
preserve real stability so
the diagonalization is rerouted and
again this is
defined okay let me
show you how the canary chandra results
follow from this
if you apply our theorem to this
polynomial here this is called the
multivariate characteristic polynomial
of a
z is again the diagonal matrix of the
variables
and yeah it is well known that this is
real stable it's easy to see that it is
multiplying
is its leading coefficient is one and if
it's diagonals its diagonal is zero then
these
coefficients become zero and
also if you differentiate with respect
to outside of sk
you just get the
multivariate characteristic polynomial
of the
principle sub matrix corresponding to sk
okay
so this is our paving
polynomial paving results now let's go
back to
uh strongly measures
so we need to apply our theorem to a
real stable polynomial the first
candidate is the
uh probability generating polynomial but
this isn't good
because uh these derivatives
don't have a really good interpretation
so uh let's do the obvious thing and
compare with determinant measures for
determinant measures we have these two
polynomials this is the
probability generating polynomial and
this is the month characteristic
multiple
variant multivariate characteristic
polynomial of the kernel
and to obtain the paving property we
need to apply our theorem
to this polynomial but in the strongly
really case we have
we only have the probability generating
polynomial so the question is what is
the
polynomial that corresponds to this
polynomial
so again we can do something simple
we find a transformation that takes this
polynomial to this polynomial
and we just apply it to this polynomial
so
let's do that this is the transformation
and we get this polynomial we can
compute
its coefficients one thing is that the
coefficients are nice
these probabilities appear as the
coefficients
and also this object which we call the
kernel polynomial
appears to be a nice object
it's some in some problems in some
settings it's more natural to
actually look at this polynomial rather
than the
probability generating polynomial
for example in our problem this is the
case
so let me show you some of the
properties of this
kernel polynomial and one thing is that
the scanner polynomial is actually some
plays a very similar similar role to the
kernel of the determinate processes
so yeah the first fact is that
this polynomial is really stable
the second one is that uh um a
multi-affine real stable polynomial
with leading coefficient one is
a kernel of a strong derailing measure
if and only if
the roots of its diagonalization are
between 0 and 1.
so this is similar to the fact that a
matrix
matrix is kernel of a determinant
process if and only if its
eigenvalues are between 0 and 1 and in
fact these roots
play a very similar role to the
eigenvalues of the kernel of a
determinant measure
so one fact about determinant measures
is that
those eigenvalues play an important role
the same thing happens here
yeah i don't have time to go through
this but i will show you
an example of this important role
later and the fact that i will use
right now is that if you restrict to any
subset then
this restriction is again strongly
rayleigh and the nice thing is that its
kernel is just this
take derivatives with respect to the
variables outside of a
okay so now
we want to apply the paving theorem
plus we needed the sum coefficient
the coefficients of the monomials of
degree one less to be
zero so we defined this polynomial here
here p i are just these probabilities
and as i mentioned before these are
the coefficients of these monomials
so uh this polynomial has these
properties it is multiplied really
stable the leading coefficient is one
these coefficients are zero so we can
apply the paving
theorem to this polynomial here and also
m of f bar is less than or equal to one
okay so now let's apply the paving
theorem
to f then we get a partition
such that this here happens again on the
right hand side we should have a
m of f bar but it was less than one
and this is let me show you again this
is the similar problem
polynomial to this for the restriction
of
x to s k okay
so what we want to do now is to
interpret this to these
these restriction restrictions to being
almost independent
which takes us back to the first problem
which has become a little bit harder
right now
so how do we solve this problem we do it
we do that by finding a connection
between the entropy of
x and the roots of the kernel polynomial
okay so yeah in particular we use the
notion of
entropy to formalize the idea of
almost independence okay
so let me just
recall that this is the definition of
entropy and
i will not use it but let's look at this
fact
uh if x is a random vector
then we have this inequality here it's
entropy is less than
this and a simple observation is that
this is just
the entropy of the independent version
of x which means
that this x hat is just a random vector
whose components are distributed as the
components of x
but they are independent so the entropy
of x
is almost always less than the entropy
of its independent version
so for a certain x we can prove that
these two sides are
close to each other it is a nice
formalization of the idea of
almost independence okay so
first let me show you the connection
between the entropy of x
and the entropy of the roots of the
kernel polynomial
so if lambda i are the roots of the
kernel polynomial then we have this
inequality
here uh recall that's lambda i
were just between 0 and 1 so this is
this right hand side is well defined
okay this theorem is actually
nice on itself but yeah we use this
and this is the main step in the proof
of the
paving property so uh
yeah let me show you finally show you
this results
it says that for every positive delta
there's an integer which only depends on
delta
such that for every strongly rayleigh
point process
x it is possible to partition the
underlying space
into our subsets such that this happens
uh okay this
is the left-hand side this is just the
entropy of the restriction of x to s k
and this is the entropy of its
independent version
so it says that the difference between
these two entropies
is less than this uh unfortunately
there's the size of sk
here i i don't think that's we can
eliminate this
but if it does if this didn't appear
here this would be a very strong result
but
yeah it disappears one way to
make it nicer is to just divide both
sides by
size of sk so if you do that you get
the mean angle particle of these two
processes so yeah this is the mean
enterprise particle
this shouldn't be here this is less than
delta so
this implies that in mean
the mean entropy particle of this
restriction is
close to its independent version so
yeah this is our formalization of the
idea that i told you about
okay
[Music]
so i think i have a couple of minutes to
go through these
open questions the first one is
applications both for the polynomial
paving theorem
and the paving property for strongly
israeli measures
uh i had this idea that
it might might be the the strongly
really paving property
should be could be useful to prove that
some measures are not strongly really
so yeah
for example one example that i tried to
apply this was
the gaussian threshold measure which is
known to be
negatively associated
but but we don't know if it is strongly
really or not
but i wasn't really successful in doing
that so
it would be nice to find applications
for these
theorems and the next two problems
uh are connected to the entropy lower
band
uh the first one
so let me go back to the
entropy lower bound so one way to look
at this is that
if uh these these are
if these are uh independent bernoulli
variables with parameters
lambda 1 to lambda n then this right
hand side is just
the entropy of this random vector
so this just says uh this becomes just
this
inequality here the second question
asks if the uh
the distribution of this random uh
this random vector majorizes the
distribution of x
so if it happens then because h is short
concave then
this follows so it is actually stronger
than the paving
than the entropy lower band and the nice
thing is that
it is true for determinant measures and
the
way we can prove this is using this
mix at this results that's
expressed expresses a determinant of
measures as a
mixture of projective determinant
measures
which means projective determinant
measures are
determinable measures with fixed size
uh so the last question
is even stronger than the first one in a
sense
it asks for for a similar result for
strongly
ready measures uh it asks if
it is possible to express an a strongly
really measure as a mixture of strongly
railing measures with
fixed size okay so we can if we can do
this
and if we characterize this mixture
nicely then
the second problem follows and
i don't know i i i think uh
i don't know if this is possible it is
possible to prove such a result because
the same result for determinant
processes uses
spectral theorems so we don't have a
similar thing here
the eigenvectors of the kernel
polynomial
kernel matrix play an important role
in this mixture for determinant measures
so
we don't have a similar object for
polynomials so
i'm not really hopeful that this would
hold but
yeah i don't know so yeah
i will stop here and thank you for
listening
thanks a lot milad and this really nice
talk any questions
could you say a bit more about what you
mean by a nice mixture so you can write
it as some mixture but so what what
exactly does nice mean
yeah it would be nice means that
you can express those uh strongly
israeli measures with fixed size
you know have a you should have a nice
expression for these
for example in the determinant of case
those projective measures become
have a relationship with the
how should i say this
yeah let me say it this way nice means
that
you should be able to express these
uh strongly measure strongly rayleigh
measures with
fixed size in a nice way in terms of the
original strongly rally measure
right for example in the determinant of
case you can do that
in terms of the eigenvectors of the
kernel of the original determinant
measure
but in here i don't know how does that
work
but if you condition on the number of
points in the subset you that condition
measure is still strongly really so the
issue is the
mixture right right right right
um yeah yeah
right one actually is a direct
generalization of the similar result for
determinant measures
that would be really nice
so do you so one question is
you do not expect uh or i do not expect
this to be algorithmic yet right
you have even for some your your main
theorem even for like spanning trees
have you thought about it is it possible
to make it algorithmic
yeah no we haven't really thought about
it i don't know i have no idea
you mean the strong israeli paving right
yeah in the last slide excuse me can
can you repeat the question
can you repeat the question thanks i
guess my so
if you go back to the last slide it
basically says that
uh you can
partition the edges of the spanning tree
this of a graph
so into this constant number of sets
such that essentially every set
is independent yes yes i was wondering
i was wondering if you can make this
algorithmic
like okay okay okay thanks a lot thanks
thanks
uh yeah but it is a good idea a good
question but
i have no idea yeah i haven't really
thought but it seems to me at least this
sk is necessary
in that case like for example if you
have a complete graph
i don't think you can you can get rid of
the sk
oh i mean i'm not
sure but it seems yeah
i think that it is impossible to do this
i mean if you look at the proof it's
really uh
saying you can construct counter
examples that there is no way yeah yeah
i don't know i mean there has to be some
scaling in the size right because
you could make the thing bigger and
bigger and then delta would basically be
zero
i mean right right it's i think the
point is
the point is you want to make you want
to see if you can make delta
independent of the size or not right you
drop
yeah but
and this property i mean do you expect
it to generalize to some
measures that have that possibly are not
negatively dependent but
have some controlled behavior like the
law concave ones or is that
is this encountering simple counter
example
oh yeah good question again
i i haven't really thought about this i
don't know i don't know
but i don't think that our proof would
work
for that we really use strongly really
real stability
we use a lot of interlacing properties
so
it's it's interesting it's interesting
because this sort of
i mean this lemma that you have that you
relate the entropy to the roots the
entropy of the roots that
that one doesn't seem to
i mean i don't know how to generalize
that to the concave distributions
right and you said you use the entropy
in the existence proof as well or no the
entropy is only used in the part one
uh existence sorry
there are two parts right there's the
yeah yeah yeah existence only
follows from the paving parts of your
paving result
which doesn't use this notion in any way
right okay